yunus et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur just another earth guest un
petit jour à jouer aujourd'hui on va se
mettre des passagers au visage à chaque
fois qu'on meurt dans ce jeu comme ça
aujourd'hui ça a pas pensé que du linge
c'est moi qui vous le dis c'est parti
alors c'est un petit jeu voilà hockey
town mais qui grosse direct alors où
elle est où sont les pics ok juste là
sur l'art et du menton mais non mais
quel homme à ce rythme là la vidéo elle
va durer une minute quattro comme c'est
drôle avait ça passe pas chez mal mais
cherche à avoir un peu de barges me sens
viril bordel on y va on y va arrête toi
j'en ai parfait la [ __ ] arrête alors
c'est quoi maintenant on va faire tout
les dédits mort ok voilà comme ça au
moins on va pouvoir jouer un peu au haut
voilà c'est ma vie en ce 1er août
allez on y va un à temps avant mai mais
non mais si l'on me couvrir de pique
sans déconner au mètre carré quoi
n'arrête non mais ce peuple est bel est
toujours un peu là au fait que deux
semaines des passages au visage crois
que ça nous amuse mais là on sait pas où
ils sont les pick up s'est enflammé les
dégoûter mieux produire pour sauter et
tout et ça vous intéresse pas ce que je
dis ah voilà c'est quoi ça une ba avons
avancé ok ils sont fait le coup
classique de la barre qui en fait ne te
fais pas j'ai compris j'ai compris a pas
de problème mais je mets la pince à
linge et je me tais ok alors si j'avais
un rouge à vue d'oeil c'est tout à fait
normal c'est qu'en fait ça fait j'ai
réussi deux excellents
c'est qu'a fait extrêmement mal mine de
rien allons le rush la speed run walla
walla walla walla attaque sur la bas
mais quoi
c'est d'abord ne tue pas à ok c'est un
truc illogique fait exprès pour trop à
les vieux trains hippiques
[ __ ] en fait là ce qu'on est en train
de faire c'est l'effet inverse du lift
et à la barre
c'est l'effet inverse du lifting en fait
on se en ce temps-là à gérer c'est à
dire cette phrase en faites pas je vais
réussir c'est à dire que quand je vais
retirer la pince à linge j'aurais pris
60 ans voilà physiquement ma peau sera
tout détendue est un la barge l'oubli à
chaque fois partout où il est possible
de mettre une pince à linge sur ce corps
il y en aura une ça commence à faire
classe real quel est le record du monde
du plus grand nombre grâce à la légère
varlet du flux grands noms de grâce à
l'injuste sur le visage crois que c'est
un truc comme deux sens la légende
raconte que le mec en retirant les 20
salles 1 j'avais la fo qui touchait ce
fait ok je veux plus faire la syllabe
feu feu feu la syllabe
voilà je veuille bien le faire signe à
l'arcade en fait tendance des années 2
les plus grands tectoniques qui leur
laver
[Musique]
pourquoi je revends du contre le côté je
cours à 1 1 quel est le fuck
après al ajial on y en eut en dieu c'est
une blague c'est une énorme blague à je
suis rappelé lazaro à la zale jura foule
a fool afful tac toc nord est où c'est
quoi ce choc quand je vais retirer tu te
fasses alors j'arrête là de joie je
salue associons de seuil de soulagement
extrême quoi comme ces niveaux de l'ère
de la phase i ont gardé fait tellement
mal l'euro auquel elle s'agite comme ça
devant un oeil
non 1 1 là il ya du coup comme ça dans
la tête rien ce texte on y vend au
niveau du rendu à salé juste reculé nec
évolue aujourd'hui au suis drôlement ne
vois que ça joue sur lui grâce à une
plus les nerfs en gros la vache on y
arrive on fait confiance à la rochelle
noir c'est la dernière passe alors qu'on
va se mettre
on se concentre
[Musique]
haha s'attachera à pescara charolles ça
les gars ça les gars ça les gars à
l'égal aller et où dario dans les
suivants et moi j'en ai marre
ah ouais j'aime les 60 ans non à merde
moi j'adore une fille de 60 ans ont du
coup je pensais que j'allais enfin
pouvoir leur plaire et tous âges bas âge
et j'ai pas dû tout assumer ce challenge
en revanche toi je te merde on va te
tuer a évoqué m'a tuer j'ai hyper mal
partout quoi c'est intéressant ou pas
ouais c'est intéressant je vais aller
enfin le bureau qui fait comme ça ok on
attend on attend on attend on attend on
attend on attend on attend
jonathan oh non il avait un élan de ski
[ __ ] non mais là on refait la à mais
c'est elle la coupable c'est la barre
jaune l'avait gardé puisque si voilà je
me la prend et si je veux pas me la
prendre je m'arrête et la lépi rassure
le tt ça fait mal un pro la vache lier
mon doigt sur les pics de jugement on
peut pas se méprendre
[ __ ] me mêle ah ouais ok le petit ses
enfants ne passent à linge à aaa elle
s'est mise sur bout du téton ça va
tellement fait mal
allez on y va alors [ __ ] ok ok ok ok
ok ok moi je pars sur un délire de
edward aux mains de pinces à linge et
nord c'est glauque un peu a fait pas mal
au niveau de merde ok on a fait des jeux
plus dur que toi d'accord alors t'as pas
le brando avec des pics à la con bonjour
je vais perdre une main pendant cette
vidéo comme la cchpb tonton georges
là-dessus il n'y a pas de problème ça
c'est clair et net
on va attendre en attendant on va
attendre et on va tuer tuer un par un
voyez le dernier à la barre au dessus je
pourrais pas tuer un bébé comme par
hasard quoi
[Musique]
la sentence est irrévocable à m
oh là là je ne plains trouve vraiment
que année par ouais mais c'est pas vrai
un peu plus tard c'est par mon gars elle
est pire que quand j'ai un coup de barre
c'est beau la fatigue à kouba bascule et
là regardez là on a un problème jackson
bail à la barre et le bonhomme voilà
[ __ ] c'est maintenant que tout va se
jouer
je savais je savais je les entendais en
dessous s'ils ont entendu rire dire tu
es prêt à y aller oui mais pour la peine
là on réussit oui c'est le facteur à à
[Musique]
ces partis bordel avec une crête sur le
nez peut-être qu'on y arrivera mieux
salo ça fait mal en plus cela fait c'est
quoi c'est pas ça là je déconnais le
ressort il est beaucoup trop puissant
ah [ __ ] j'en ai marre un jour ça
passera un jour fera de grandes choses
c'est sûr
alès de plus je joue cratère s cette
fois on y croire qu'on peut y arriver
squeeze termine alors en position
latérale de sécurité
[Musique]
bon on vient voir cette vidéo sur un jeu
de merde voilà je te paie schubert et ce
n'est pas la vidéo ça vous a plu je
pensais pas que ça faisait aussi mal de
ce fait des passages sur le visage mais
en fait c'est vraiment très douloureux
après peut-être celle là elle sert pas
de clairement fort mais j'ai pas
l'impression peut-être suis juste très
faible ça va regarder ce ton très
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo j'ai
pratiqué la pls aujourd'hui c'est un
grand moment où se trouvait dans une
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien chat ou
le monde pis
[Musique]